dossier de notre journal consacré au
tennis aujourd'hui début des
internationaux de france à roland garros
pendant deux semaines deux cent mille
spectateurs vont assister déjà des
résultats
aujourd'hui georges goven a été éliminé
par l'italien aux clefs pau en quatre
manches pour nous parler de roland
garros sur place de niffer des qui en a
fait sa page spéciale bienvenu ici au
stade roland garros ou pages transports
s'est déplacé pour être au coeur de
l'événement sportif de la quinzaine
les internationaux de france de tennis
sur terre battue qui réunissent toute
l'élite du tennis mondial depuis ce
matin ce sera pour nous l'occasion de
voir tout ce que représente ce rendez
vous tennistique parisien et de faire le
point sur les nouvelles installations du
stade de la porte d'auteuil celles déjà
réalisées et celles du futur roland
garros fait peau neuve
les habitués des internationaux de
france ne vont pas reconnaître leur
vieux centrale avec sa tribune tout neuf
roland garros a maintenant 51 ans et six
en un demi-siècle il n'avait pas
beaucoup changé le tennis en revanche a
beaucoup évolué et le joyau de 1928 et
est devenu un stade un peu vieillot ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que depuis les
cinq dernières années on a fait
énormément de travaux qui sont peut-être
pas spectaculaire parce que cet effet
sous les gradins on l'a fait par exemple
on l'a investi à peu près 5 millions de
francs.le quatre dernières années
l'essentiel de cette somme a été
investie dans des travaux qui ont permis
de très nette amélioration des
conditions de travail de la presse entre
autres les vestiaires également ou été
modernisé et puis pour les joueurs un
club a été créé
c'était le moins qu'on pouvait faire
pour un sport en pleine évolution a le
tennis actuellement sur suscité un
engouement extraordinaire en france et
notamment juan carlos qui est devenu un
très bon tournoi et nous avons été
obligés stone et la vendée les tribunes
pour pouvoir recevoir tout public qu'il
veut assister au match qui lie à l'heure
actuelle roland garros deuxièmement la
ville de paris nous a donné
l'autorisation de récupérer le goût de
terrain qui était dans le pâté de maison
appartenait avant
l'institut marais et nous avons
construit un mini centrale de 4500
places qui remplace actuellement un
central avec tribunes démontables n'est
pas très pratique
coût de l'opération 1 milliard de
centimes
les plus gros travaux ne sont pas encore
terminées tout devrait être prêt fin 80
et alors là avec son central bis roland
garros sera très conventionnel avec
nouveaux vestiaires restaurants
supplémentaires et centres de formation
et puis toujours pour 1980 une autre
aire de jeux sera construite qui pourra
accueillir 1000 spectateurs
enfin dernière innovation les actuels
courts couverts seront démontées et
remplacés par six loups au cours trois
couverts en dessous et 3 découvert au
dessus alors tout ça c'est beau mais on
peut se demander s'il n'était pas
préférable de construire un nouveau
stade
qu'on soit à nouveau stade il en est des
questions en 72
avec une participation d'ailleurs de
l'état pour en faire tout un nouveau
stade et puis finalement il ya eu la
crise du pétrole le dossier passé par en
dessous
et puis on n'est plus question
maintenant saleh 18000 places je crois
c'est une capacité emploi ximum pour le
tennis on peut pas envisager pour le
tennis d'avoir un châle de 30 à 35 mille
places parce que la balle de tennis et
est ce qu'elle est c'est par un ballon
de football et je pense que là c'est
vraiment le maximum pour avoir une bonne
vision de partout sur le sol centrale
voilà roland garros est prêt il sera
encore plus beau l'an prochain mais le
tennis peut commencer
eric deblicker numéro 3 français et vous
vous êtes un pur produit un peu self
tennisman puisque n'existait pas toutes
ces structures quand vous avez débuté
comment êtes vous devenu alors ce que
vous êtes aujourd'hui mais je crois que
c'est notre force de travail maintenant
j'ai moins eu la chance d'appartenir à
un club qui a quand même des structures
assez importante qui aurait su un peu
m'entoure et me conseiller et je crois
que j'ai grâce à ce club j'ai quand même
pu devenir et me hisser à une place
c'est honorable dans le tennis français
maintenant effectivement tout le monde
n'a pas la chance d'appartenir au racing
et je crois que il se pose des problèmes
au niveau certainement parents de la
banlieue de paris parce que les clubs
ont des petites infrastructures il
manque souvent de courts de tennis et je
crois que là la fédération un rôle
important à jouer dans la mesure
justement de d'augmenter un peu là la
capacité des courts de tennis